in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 17th, on which we commemorate the Holy Martyrs,
Manual, Sable and Ismail. These glorious martyrs were three brothers
from a noble Persian family, instructed by their mother in Christian doctrine and confided
to a priest, Yonikos, for their education, they led a devout life.
They were greatly honored at the court of King Botanos to such a degree that when Julian
the Apostate sent peace proposals to Persia, the king chose them to go to Constantinople
as ambassadors. They were received with great respect, and Julian invited them to join him
at court, and go to sumptuous feasts near Calcedon, in the course of which there would
be sacrifices to the gods. Everyone took part in the sacrifices except
the three young Persian ambassadors who turned away in disgust from the display of impiety
and drew back into a corner to pray to God with tears, to give the light of the knowledge
of him to those who lay in darkness. When a Chamberlain came to summon them to take
part in the sacrifice, they replied that their mission was to negotiate a peace treaty
between the two kingdoms, and in no way to give credit to the apostate by denying their
faith. Informed of this unexpected resistance on the part of the Persians, Julian at once
had them imprisoned, and they appeared before him the next day. He tried at first to influence
them with flattery, vaunting the worship of fire and the sun practiced by the Persians.
But the three young men replied through an interpreter that they were disciples of Jesus Christ,
and that there was nothing in the world that would make them return to the senseless cult
of their forefathers, turning from the Creator to worship creatures.
Julian, in a fury, had them beaten by four soldiers, then had their hands nailed to a stake.
He ordered that their bodies be flayed with iron nails. Their spirits fixed on the passion
of Christ the Holy Martyrs prayed to the Lord to help them endure the suffering with patience,
and immediately an angel appeared to heal their wounds and give them renewed strength.
When they appeared once more before the tyrant, they declared that they were ready to undergo
further torture with joy and delight. Julian then took Sable and Ismail aside and attempted
to sway them by accusing their brother, but having tried in vain he sent them to the torturers
for their ribs to be burned with torches. Feeling no pain, so great was their joy at sharing
in Christ's passion, the saints continued to proclaim the Savior's power with loud voices.
The emperor then turned to manual, but the saint, refusing to pay the slightest attention
to his threats, said to him, Why are you giving yourself so much trouble, you fool? It
is useless to try to separate us. We are all three united by faith in the Holy Trinity,
and whatever one of us declares is the resolute conviction of the other two. Nothing can make
us change. We will not exchange eternal blessings for that which is vain and transitory, realizing
that he would gain nothing and that he was risking the possibility of numerous conversions
among his own people. Julian ordered that manuals armpits be burned, and then that he be
bound strongly with reeds and pierced with arrows. He then ordered the torturers to knock
nails into the heads and shoulder blades of the three martyrs, and then insert reeds under
their nails, before be heading them, and finally throwing their bodies into the sea.
They then took them outside the city of Constantinople to an escarpment to the east of Constantin's
wall, and the saints, after having raised a prayer of thanksgiving to Christ, which was
answered by a heavenly voice, were executed. As soon as they had taken their last breath,
the earth opened and protected their bodies for two days, sheltered from the pagan searching.
They then reappeared miraculously, and the Christians waiting there were able to give them
worthy burial. A church was later built above their tomb in which the saints worked many
miracles. Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy
on us, and save us.